I usually advise against reading YouTube
comments but if you read the YouTube
comments for this trailer they are so
sweet
John's involved instant oh that's so
cool well look I mean you should it
should be an instant buy for the team
that makes it hey I'm John good to be
here this is bambam the dog Jon Bernthal
brings his dog on stage for his
presentation of Ghost Recon break point
where he takes on a villainous role I'm
a wolf
raised via uncanny to look at its amazed
what these guys can do I play Colt
Walker who was a ghost is he's got the
same training but his mission and his
mindset have changed pretty drastically
and so I would say he's definitely an
antagonist but someone who believes in
his cause vitally and and and with with
with with real passion it's gotta be a
fun role to play though I love an
antagonist who you kind of believe in
what they're doing a little bit it's
gotta be that way it's got nobody wakes
up in the morning says I'm a bad guy
he's doing the right thing let's talk
about the motion capture experience what
kind of different muscles does that flex
for you as an actor I think number one
you're in these crazy suits with all
these dots all over your face and lights
in your eyes but you get over that
pretty fast I think one of the things
about the process that I really loved
and was a was a really unique challenge
was you every scene that you shoot
you've got to get it done in one perfect
take because there's cameras all over
the room and every angle is being
covered at once and I like that I think
it brings out the best in everybody
there's a sense of you know there's a
real sense of urgency and that you've
got to get it right and I like that it's
like theater there's no place to hide
you know if there's cameras everywhere
and I dig that part of me wishes more
film and television were shot that way
it's a real honor and I think a
responsibility anytime you play
a member of the military and these are
all Special Forces guys guys who train
in the Special Forces and there was no
time that we were on set that there
weren't real Special Forces soldiers
there critiquing us helping us training
us they have the ability to stop a take
and say that's not real so as far as the
way we can
our weapons used our weapons the way we
moved the way we spoke they were an
integral part of the entire process
which is something that I care about
deeply it takes such a long time and all
these people all over the globe sort of
making this but to a person there was no
person who this sort of felt like a job
it was a it's a passion it's a
responsibility it's an honor you know
they everybody really wanted to get this
right and those are the kind of projects
I want to be part of last time I talked
to you that morning it was announced you
were doing The Sopranos pretty cool what
is the latest on that what is it like
working with Michael Gandolfini Oh Mikey
I love him I love Mike yeah yeah I love
him you know we've just wrapped it was
great it was great I'm really honored
just sort of be a part of Michael's
journey he's a beautiful young man who
this obviously means an unbelievable
amount to I think he's sort of
approaching it with the highest level of
integrity in honoring this show and
honoring his father I think he's a
beautiful artist that's that's enormous
ly talented and I think folks are gonna
he did this the right way he really
really worked hard and I think people
are gonna really dig what he did and and
he's gonna be a friend of mine for life
I really love getting to know him
[Music]
[Applause]